just when you thought summer was getting
good August hits you like a train wreck
but don't worry August also means we're
only one month away from Apple's
September event and let me tell you this
is gonna be the biggest one in years so
let's jump right into seven things you
should expect at this event now the
first one is something a lot of people
aren't expecting at all and that's the
new iPad Air 6 which I'm not gonna spend
too much time on because this is a
pretty simple update it'll mainly be a
quick chip swap from the M1 to the M2 as
well as updated Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
specs and then maybe a faster USBC port
and potentially a switch over to the
horizontal camera layout now the second
thing to expect is actually the new
Apple watch series 9 which is gonna look
very similar to the current model on the
outside with no design changes at all
but it's what's on the inside that
counts for the first time in many years
the chip is finally going to be getting
a big upgrade to the new S9 processor
which will be based on the five
nanometer technology from the a15 chip
now if you didn't already know the
actual chip itself hasn't really changed
since the S6 which launched with the
Apple Watch series 6. Apple has
literally just been rebranding the same
chip for the S7 and the S8 so it's a big
deal that it's getting updated this time
around which should lead to better
battery life and snappier performance
now if you're waiting for a new SE Apple
watch don't because that is not
happening this year instead we're
getting an updated Ultra model but
before I get into those details I want
to get into what everyone wants to hear
about which is the iPhone 15 lineup as
number three and I actually have some
brand new leak updates you're not going
to want to miss if you think the iPhone
Ultra is coming think again because
because this year we're gonna have the
regular iPhone 15 the 15 plus the 15 Pro
and the 15 Pro Max just like last year
however Mark German just came out on
Sunday and mentioned that the entire
lineup might see a price increase of at
least 50 depending on where you live all
the way up to potentially two hundred
dollars for the pro Max which was
recently suggested by an analyst at
Barclays and I made a whole video with
10 reasons why the price will be going
up which you can check out after this
video but Mark German actually mentioned
one of these main reasons and that's the
brand new titanium finish that'll be
exclusive to the Pro Models and as we
already know Apple charges a premium of
a hundred dollars for titanium Apple
watches over this stainless steel models
but as far as what else to expect we
recently got a league saying that the
regular iPhone 15 model will actually
get the incredible 48 megapixel camera
that I thought would be reserved to the
Pro Models only but this sensor size
won't be quite as big as on the pros the
regular models should also get the new
redesigned sides which will have rounded
edges as well as an updated Ultra
wideband chip which will hit the entire
lineup to help support the Vision Pro
headset coming next year and of course
we have the switch to USBC on all of
them which I'm very excited for since my
lightning cables can literally go
bye-bye especially since I charge my
airpods exclusively with wireless
charging but the Pro Models are where
it's at because they'll support even
faster transfer speeds as well as a
bunch of other upgrades like the jump up
to Wi-Fi 6E and eight gigs of RAM which
will help with app snappiness and
multitasking Mark German also just
confirmed that the Pro Models will have
thinnest bezels on any smartphone in the
world just 1.5 millimeters thin down
from 2.2 millimeters on the 14 Pros
which is crazy and that's what I'm
really excited for the Pro Models will
also feature an upgraded lidar scanner
as well as apparently a more repairable
design that Apple introduced into the
regular 14 and 14 plus models but not
the pros just yet but before we get into
the feature that I'm most excited about
I've got to show you the best earbuds
I've ever heard in my life the nhb12s
from our sponsor Quest style which are
the world's first true lossless
earphones with official mfi
certification so you can simply plug
them into your iPhone and enjoy high-res
lossless audio which only works thanks
to an inline custom DAC and amplifier
which includes two LEDs which light up
to show you whether it's Regular Music
or high-res lossless that's playing and
yes these destroy Apple's airpods Pro 2
in every way so check them out using the
link in the description below but the
biggest new standout feature for the Pro
Models will be the exclusive action
button which will be able to be
customized to do a bunch of different
things like turn on silent mode turn on
the flashlight trigger commands and
shortcuts open the camera and record
videos and even start voice recording as
well now the one that I'm personally
excited to use the most is the new
Periscope zoom camera on the pro Max
exclusively which will have a huge
upgrade for long range Zoom shots and
videos now let's get into the fourth
thing which is of course the Apple watch
Ultra 2. while we don't know much about
exactly what Apple's gonna do with this
upgraded watch One Thing Mark German
just revealed to us on Sunday is that
Apple actually tested a black black
titanium option last year with the ultra
but they decided against releasing it
now while there aren't much leaks out
there in terms of Apple creating a
smaller version of the ultra it could
actually make sense because right now
there are a lot of people who would love
to have the ultra design and battery
life but the size is simply too big for
their wrist so Apple can scoop up a ton
of upgrade demand just by making the
ultra a little bit smaller opening it up
to a lot of people with those smaller
wrists so I'm really hoping Apple will
do this because it'll be very
interesting to see but I personally have
been loving my ultra so far now getting
into the fifth thing we of course have
the official launch of new software like
iOS 17 which I'm personally really
excited for for things like nightstand
mode that makes it so much more useful
when charging at night and on top of
that there will be upgrades for things
like your earpods enabling the Adaptive
mode which automatically switches
between the transparency and noise
cancellation modes so you basically
never have to do it yourself we'll also
be getting all the other Mac OS and iPad
OS software updates that'll continue to
make our Apple products even better so
I'm excited for all of that now moving
on to the sixth thing to expect at
Apple's event next month it's actually
something that's a bit of a hit or miss
it's now been two years since the
airpods 3 have been on the market and we
conveniently have been seeing leaks
about Apple releasing a brand new pair
of airpods referred to as a low-cost
airpods light and the reasons for this
is that the airpods 3 haven't been doing
so well in terms of sales with consumers
either choosing the high-end airpods Pro
or just going with some less expensive
options on the market so a lower cost
light airpods model could be perfect to
scoop up that demand however what if
these leaked earpods already came in the
form of Beats Studio buds plus because
if you think about it we had similar
leaks about a new airpods Max Sport
model but that simply turned out to just
be the Beats Studio Pro headphones not
an airpods product at all and now
finally for thing number seven this is
one that's not really based on any
concrete leaks out there but it makes
sense seeing as this is Apple's biggest
event of the year so this will be a bit
of a prediction on my part I believe
that apple is going to be giving people
of of severance since the first season
was released about a year and a half ago
and even with the rider strike going on
I believe Apple will be giving us some
sort of a sneak peek at the September
event to get everybody hyped and I hope
it's not just hopium because I've
watched Severance season one three
separate times already I just really
want season two and as for the other
products we're not really expecting any
other iPads Macs Apple TVs or anything
else at this event with us likely
waiting until October for the new M3 Max
so hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did go ahead and check out that
video that goes through the 10 reasons
for why apple is Raising iPhone prices
over there and definitely subscribe up
there as well thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
foreign